foods are for a dunk
here he comes the other way there's your
first James Jam of his career
whoa stand up and light a match this is
getting out of control
[Applause]
that's not all he's done though the next
time
[Applause]
yes and the foul
my goodness
you could see that one coming a mile
away Mark that one out Barbosa going to
the ramp and LeBron James
blocks it from behind
LeBron at the other end slams it oh baby
then it transition D out knowing he has
5 fouls the statue has trying to take
the charge LeBron too good
down by one
Max Steel defending on James the
problems
[Applause]
[Music]
with no regard for human life
whoa before he has not been able to get
in the lane but man oh man what a
fluctuating dump from LeBron James
oh my goodness power speed well this is
the guy who's put his hat into the slams
of competition for next year
I will present the All-Star Game most
viable player but Anthony Parker hit his
first two
shot clock is down to five
nice take by James
LeBron James puts him well click click
get ready for your Kodak moment
fakes Baseline goes middle The Flash
balls goes off poster Jennings for three
I will take out a touch but it goes to
Wade he has Arroyo in front
of Bounce to James if you miss
especially some of the key pieces of
Dwyane Wade with another steal three on
one James
holy smokes you kidding me the way they
get out in transition Jason Terry good
defense Wade from behind takes it away
Chalmers whoa
[Applause]
now it looked like he jumped out of the
mezzanine to dump the spawn I just watch
as they lay it up there watch this
oh
that's sending it down with some power
[Applause]
you can see it coming
and shake it it is you know how strong
that basket is
registered
I'm a slam dunk skin he played for Pete
Carrillo at correction
[Music]
all right
wow has been doing about the Flies been
doing it with the outside shots
puts it down
LeBron James with an outstanding first
half and that's what's happening so far
touch toss to J.R Smith to LeBron James
that was insane
officially insane LeBron James 40 points
for messers love and James the loudest
right there as a kip record puts the
Cavaliers up myself
Curry on Irving Irving the drive back to
James
Lee and a foul LeBron James dribble
penetration to blow by LeBron James
taking two guys and finishing at The Rim
my goodness Mama there goes that man
Team 13 Portland back in front LeBron
turned the corner inside
[Applause]
her
15-14 that Kepler bench is going nuts
higher Bosnian Army to stop
listen to it again there's that length
again that time being used on the glass
do you see the reach I'm talking about
that is incredible who's the can't
finish but
certainly can
the Lakers in must win mode a good hard
drive there's the follow why just dunk
it when you can reverse dunk it the king
is in the house
and it's worthy of multiple looks
shoot 38 from downtown Here Comes l
ol oh the crowd on their feet and the
crowd wasn't
as quite as noisy there as it was here
I'll tell you that's some play by LeBron
James the buzz lasted for about half a
minute like you said you know there's
the yardstick that I like to use for the
Lakers when kcp is
involved and active offensively this
Laker team can be very tough
throw it down with that King
15-11. what a play by LeBron James and
that forces a timeout with the Lakers up
by four
at home against the Pelican shorts
awesome rules stew is there to get the
fresh 14 for the Lakers LeBron
oh my Lord oh
my Lord gets his a poster as LeBron just
elevates and just hammers it
true
[Applause]
first slam from Schroeder as well as a
player tonight you gotta see it again
[Applause]
did you say this was his 20th season did
you just tell me he had a birthday and
turned 38. don't believe it
unbelievable athleticism